[Musique]
moi
tout là bas au fond de la forêt vierge
africaine les animaux sauvages et
distant corps à l'hébertot alertes des
chasseurs cachez-vous ses débuts un
credo lyon bat les débats les cache toi
mais cache comité jeunesse avant de voir
[Musique]
c'est raté
et parce que vous faites mais la chaleur
et ne vous a rien fait pauvre en crayon
lyon on va tous à tous tantôt il ya un
créneau lyon qui pleure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attention ils ont des armes
[Musique]
à
oh
voyons parmi les animaux que l'on ne
chasse pas avec un fusil il y à rien
je suis sous les moustiques à la pac
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et oui vois toi ton tu as raison le
safari photo c'est bien plus amusant que
de chasser avec un fusil et regardez le
credo lyon vous fait en prime des
sourires
[Musique]
mais voilà c'est pas plus sympathique
comme ça allez au revoir les chasseurs
fait de belles photos merci watts où
va-t-on
[Musique]